start so it's
you know we always say it's my great
pleasure but with curtis it is truly my
great pleasure
and the reason is that curtis is my
student
and he's
[Music]
completed his phd into 2017 and he
worked on this
common a tool called math check which is
a combination of computer algebra
systems and sat solvers
aimed at solving mathematical problems
subsequent to that curtis was a postdoc
in my group for a couple of years
and then he did a post-doc with kevin
chung and brett stevens at
carlton following which now he's a
professor
at the university of windsor and i call
him kurt
hi so it's like the plural of curtis
because he's so productive
so without further ado kurtai please
take away
oh thank you thank you vijay for the
gracious introduction and
i like to particularly thank the
organizers for
running this great workshop and giving
me this uh
you know it's my honor to present uh my
research on
uh computer algebra and sat and for how
we can apply them to
all math problems all right so let me
start with uh
motivation so we all know that
mathematicians are utterly fascinated
with searching for structures
particularly ones which satisfy
really elegant properties right so i
have two quick examples on the side here
on the left i have a graph and i've
colored the edges of the graph so that
every
vertex is adjacent to exactly one edge
of each color
on the right i have a chess board and i
put a queen in every square
all right i've colored the queen so that
queens which could attack each other
are colored differently right this just
means every row column and diagonal
of the board is colored differently
right and so you can imagine either
coming up with some kind of mathematical
theoretical way of constructing these
things or writing a computer program
which would perform a search and look
for uh
such colorings a third example
which is near and dear to my heart is
hadamard matrices
this is also very uh a mathematical
object which is defined really elegantly
so we have a square matrix and all the
entries are either plus or minus one
and the defining property is that any
two rows of the matrix
should be orthogonal to each other right
so they're mutually orthogonal this is a
very restrictive condition
and people scientists have studied these
things for
over 100 years they've used them in
statistics and coding theory to
for example when they were communicating
with probes being sent to mars
you want to encode a data cent in some
kind of error
correcting fashion one way to do that is
to use the rows
of your hadamard matrix to form the code
words right and then this orthogonality
property is saying that two code words
are kind of maximally distinct
right so it has good error correcting
properties in any sense these things are
really interesting from just a
theoretical standpoint
and mathematicians have studied them for
a long time and trying to construct them
in as many orders as possible
one mathematician who did this was john
williamson in 1944
and he actually found the example shown
on this slide here so this is an eight
by eight
had a bug matrix but he actually went
further he this was an amazing paper
he found many different examples of hat
of our matrices
here's another one this is a 16x16 and
it's formed
you can kind of see how its construction
works it's formed by
submatrices known as williamson matrices
in this case they're order
four and you put them together in this
nice pattern and you get something which
is handmart
now remember he did this without
computers so it was a very impressive
paper because he actually went up to
here's a order eight williamson matrices
order 16 and believe it or not
order using order 32 williams of
matrices he got up to
128 by 128. all right so this is an
amazing piece of work because he did it
all by hand right he
proved theorems about them and they used
those theorems and then
some kind of trial and error process to
find these examples
now the interesting thing was you know
he got them up to two to the five all
the powers of two up to 32
and then he says well it would be nice
to know whether these things
were in some general you know there's a
general theorem
you know does this pattern always extend
this would be nice to do he couldn't
you know the computations become too
involved he was only able to give these
explicit examples he gave some other
examples
but he didn't have a general theorem
actually this was an open problem
from 1944 up to a few years ago it was
not even known
if there was a williamson matrix of
order 64.
until we ran searches for willington
matrices we actually ran
exhaustive searches up to order 70 in
all even orders
right the searches found many examples
of williamson matrices and in fact
many examples in order 64 we
examined the patterns which were in
those matrices and actually extended it
right they
they go to all powers of two so now we
actually have a general theorem which
says
williams matrices do exist in all powers
of two so the moral of the story
is sometimes you really want
these computational searches right it's
great when you can come up with some
kind of theoretical construction
but that's not always possible or it's
it's very hard to do
right but when you get all this
exhaustive searches
via computational means you're able to
examine the data
and then sometimes actually prove uh
you know a general construction so to
give you a sense of the state of the art
previous to this uh there's two fields
which
have been used to search for volumes and
matrices one was sad solving and one was
computer algebra
uh computer algebra the state of the art
in 2006 was to search for williamson
matrices up to order 22.
and then in 2016 the state of the art
using a stat approach
was to search for williamson matrix he's
up to order 30.
all right so remember we got up to order
70.
so this really demands an explanation
right
you might be thinking well okay this is
pretty good it's more than double the
order but remember this is an
exponentially sized growing search base
right order 70
the search base in order 70 is over 25
orders of magnitude larger
than the search base in order 30. right
so this is not just slightly
faster this is astronomically faster
it's like you would think it'd be
impossible
to exhaustively search a search base of
this magnitude but
indeed it actually is feasible and so
then my goal for the rest of this talk
is to give you an intuition
why it's able to get up to you know why
we're able to search such enormous
search bases
so i don't have to spend too much time
on set i assume
most of the people in the workshop are
familiar with this right this is the
classic
satisfiability problem from logic and
sad sellers are very
effective at finding uh solutions to the
sat problem
all right so some of the things are used
for they stand far you know the
applications
extend far beyond logic they're used for
hardware and software verification
they're used for solving map problems
for for example marine
has uh lots of results in this line for
on the right here this is the coloring
of the integers
from 1 to 160 subject to the constraint
that a and b
and a plus b are never colored the same
now the interesting thing is
this does actually not extend to 161.
160 is the maximum number of col
integers that you can color using five
colors and so this is
what morin showed with a sat silver that
it's impossible to go
to 161 right and so you can use the set
server also provides unsatisfiability
certificates
when something is unsatisfiable and so
this is also a very important property
of sense solving
now sat sellers are great when they work
well but sometimes they also
will fail and this is also very well
known right and embarrassingly sometimes
they'll actually fail on totally
trivial problems the classic example of
this is
the pigeonhole principle right so
imagine you have 20 pigeons
and you have 19 holes and you want to
find a way to put the pigeons into
the holes every hole is only large
enough to contain one pigeon well
obviously this is impossible all right
there's no computation that has to be
done here besides just counting the
pigeons and holes but
you know any a mathematician can
obviously see this but a sat solver
remember when you're translating a
problem into sat you lose the context
the satire doesn't see pigeons and holes
it's not it's just these truths and
falses
all right and it only makes the most
basic logical inferences it doesn't
think at a high level
the way a mathematician thinks so in
fact it'll actually take exponential
time on this problem
basically trying to put every pigeon in
every hole
which brings me to the computer algebra
system all right
this was my background before i started
working in sat and you can think of a
computer algebra system or
at least i think of it as executing
mathematics on a computer
right it allows you to work with
mathematical objects at a very high
level
kind of the way mathematician does so an
example this would be
you give it a matrix you can give you
the row reduction
you can compute the closed form solution
of integrals or sums or transforms
you can compute with symmetries in
groups an exam another example on the
slide here is
give give it two separate uh graphs
these are eight vertices and each vertex
says degree three
and the question is are they isomorphic
are they actually the same graph
in disguise and in this case you give it
to a
cast like maple it'll actually come back
with not just
the answer it'll tell you if they are
isomorphic
explicit permutation of the
vertices which will make the graphs the
same right so i've actually color coded
some edges here
to show you the structure and reveal
that yes these are the same graphs
okay so casters are great as well but
from my perspective in my research
they're not so great at doing
this sort of exponential size search
base for example in the williamson
example when you have like a huge space
that you want to look through
but if you think back to a stat solver
what the stat solver is doing is
inherently a search problem
right it's trying to find that needle in
the haystack maybe there's only one
satisfying assignment of your formula
right and you're tasked with trying to
find it right you're trying to find that
needle
in this exponentially large sized
haystack
so if sad sellers are good at anything
they must be good at the search problem
right they're
dealt to they're built to cope with that
immenseness
whereas in a way that casts is typically
aren't so when you say it like this
this is a very natural paradigm right in
hindsight
sat solvers are really great at search
cats are really great at math and
there's lots of mathematical problems
where you want
the power of both right you want fast
search and you want expressive
mathematics
surprisingly this was you know both of
the
these two fields were very well
developed going back to the
beginning of computer science it's kind
of surprising that
it's not only until relatively recently
that these fields
uh started interacting with each other
all right so it was noticed
in uh 2015 by erika abraham and others
that these two fields really have much
to learn from each other
right and they organized a workshop the
first one being at digital in
2015 and they you know since then the
pro
this has been like a budding new field
of research there's been
associates of this sc squared project
and over 40 universities and 15
companies so people are really starting
to take notice
and using the techniques of both fields
to solve problems that
couldn't otherwise be solved with using
just the techniques of one field
this is also where i entered the picture
like
ej said i was doing a phd at waterloo
and we started working with
match check kind of it was actually
independently we derived devised this
first
snap plus cast system that we called
math check and so we use mat check as i
mentioned to search for
uh how to mark matrices this is one of
our first applications
and you can see on the right here this
is one of the
100 000 hadamard matrices that we found
this is actually a cross stitch
of a hadamard matrix uh designed
actually by my partner
you know this it's really nice to be
able to put your research into like this
nice visual form right so it's a nice
way to
actually see the matrix in any case this
was only one
of a hundred thousand right so we were
like really excited that
you know even at the first one and then
we you know we just kept finding them
so and i'm you know happy to report uh
the
the work we did on uh lamb's problem
recently won a best paper award last
year
and so i want to talk for the rest of
the talk uh
mostly focused on on land's problem
right but i just do want to mention we
did solve
many different problems from many
different domains of mathematics
uh shown on the slide here so if you're
interested uh
yeah i'm happy to take any questions or
you can check out our other papers
now let me give you just give me a
couple minutes to talk about the history
of land's problem because this is
it has a very interesting history dating
back all the way to
euclid in 300 bc
so euclid did something interesting
right he was the divisor
of the axioms of geometry he wanted to
put it on a sound foundation
and he devised five axioms which he said
characterize all geometric truths
interesting thing was four of the axioms
were totally simple
the fifth axiom known as the parallel
postulate was much more complicated
everyone agreed that it was definitely
true but
you know they wanted some people were
unsettled by it was so much more
complicated than the simpler axioms
right they wanted to prove this
parallel postulate in terms of the
simpler axioms they tried to do this for
2000 years
and they consistently failed and there
was a reason why
the reason was noticed in the 1800s
starting with the work of gauss and
others
there are alternative models of geometry
where the parallel postulate
will not hold it will be false so let me
give you one slide of
summary of what these geometries would
look like so imagine you have your
euclidean plane
and you stick it on the ground right and
you're standing out and you're looking
at parallel lines
and you look at them they go off to the
horizon it looks as if they meet on the
horizon right like train tracks
now the horizon's not actually a line so
they don't actually meet but
imagine you just added in the horizon as
a line
into this plane and once you make that
intuitive leap you realize
now you have a new model of geometry
where parallel lines don't exist
and this is what's known as a projective
plane and interestingly despite an
immense amount of study there's still
open questions about projective planes
we don't even know
all the projected planes which exist uh
even
if there's only a finite number of
points so what does what does
would this mean right what's a finite
projective plane i've given you a couple
of
uh examples on the slide here it's it's
nice because you can just draw them out
and you know they're nice and colorful
drawings here you might be looking them
and saying okay well wait a minute
this doesn't look like any geometry i've
ever seen right first of all
you're saying this purple circle is a
line and yes it is a line
based on the definition of a line right
the definition is given above right the
sata line is a set of
lines and points satisfy these axioms
and this is going to be our definition
the main axiom here is if you take any
two lines
they meet at a unique point all right
one and only one point
and then an order is going to be one
greater than the number of points on the
line
okay so why do
i bring this up because people have
studied these things for hundreds of
years
and they have not yet succeeded in
classifying
for what orders projected planes exist
we know the answer up to 10.
so they don't exist in order six this
can be ruled out mathematically by a
theoretical obstruction
they exist in every other order so you
can just give a construction
now 10 is the very interesting case this
is lamb's problem nobody knows a
projected plan of order 10
and yet nobody knows any theoretical
reason why one shouldn't exist
so you could conjecture either way
indeed people had conjectured either way
either it exists some people thought
existed some people thought it didn't
it's named after clement lam who was a
mathematician at concordia university in
montreal
in honor of him because he extensively
studied this problem
in the 1980s for a complete decade
essentially
and in the end with a team of
programmers they were able to resolve
the problem they actually got a lot of
press for it because this was
like i said a centuries-old problem and
they solved it in the negative they ran
a computer search for months on the
most powerful super computer of the era
it was a
a cray one they did not find the
projected plane
so this was a proof that it didn't exist
but the proof is you know in quotation
marks some people were kind of unsettled
by it because
you know it was using custom written
software
around a single time on a single piece
of hardware
and at the end of the day there's
nothing to check how do we know
that the computations were successful
you don't you just have to trust them
right
maybe there was a hardware glitch or a
computer
there was a bug in the software or there
was an administrative error
all these things are actually not that
unlikely right this was a very
hard computation to uh to do and so some
mathematicians thought
you know they'd really dreamt of uh
something more verifiable something that
could be certified
by an independent party this is where we
come in
we actually gave the first verifiable
proof of lamb's problem
uh we did this as i will describe using
reduction to sat
and then used what's known as the cube
and conquer method to
solve the sat instances so this is a
method pioneered by marine and
oliver coleman and the other other uh
collaborators
and you know it's an amazing method when
it works you can you can look at
their talks on it i'll just say what
what it does is you
take this huge stat instance and you
split it up into like bite-sized chunks
all right this has two main benefits one
is that you can fire it off on a cluster
apparel using parallelization each of
the sub chunks are independent and of
approximately equal difficulty and
second it actually
works extremely well with sat solver sad
sellers perform much better on these
bite-sized chunks than they do
on just one large problem so you
actually got a super linear time speed
up
if things uh if everything works
correctly
okay so cuban conquer is not enough
on its own to solve the problem because
as i mentioned sat solvers
do not know the mathematics behind the
problem
people had studied the projected plane
of order 10 for dec you know
for centuries and they come up with a
lot of
theorems about it properties that it
must satisfy
and we would want to exploit these
theorems in
our search right and so let me give you
first just a quick summary of how we can
do the encoding
right how are you going to code this on
a boolean logic formula
so it's actually not too not too bad you
obviously we don't use these nice
colorful diagrams we're going to use
what's known as an instance matrix
so you take your lines of the plane
you're going to make them
rows of this incidence matrix you take
your points of the plane you make them
columns of the matrix
and then if you take the ith line and if
it contains the jth
point you put an ah a one in the ijth
entry here
otherwise it'll be the zero so in sat
context you just let
you have a variable for every entry in
the matrix and the variable is going to
be
true if that entry is a one the variable
is going to be false as the entries a
zero
right so you just define a bunch of
variables and then you come up with a
a conjunctive normal form encoding of
the axioms of a projected plane it's
actually not too difficult i won't get
into all the details
because i want to focus on the sapless
cast
method right what can we use the cast
for
and there's many things one of the
uh first of all how is the sense solver
work well it's doing like a partial
finding partial solutions right it's
going to assign some variables to true
some variables to false some variables
are going to be left under
undefined and then it finds solutions
which satisfy
the constraints up to some point right
example here on the slide
i've given you a four point and six line
partial
projective plane all right so when you
find this partial solution you give it
to the cast
the cast can then analyze it using the
theorems that it knows about the
projective plane right in some cases you
can just eliminate the solution
or you can do is you can analyze it and
then shrink the search space
further a classic example of this is
you analyze the symmetries of the
partial structure that you found in this
case look at it and rotate it
180 degrees if you rotate it 180 degrees
you get
something which is looks the same that
means you can block it
right they're isomorphic there's no
sense in searching the space defined by
the second
example because it's going to be the
same as this space
defined by the first example right so we
can block the second
and go on this go on on the rest of the
search
why is this this is important because
every single time you find a new
symmetry
you can shrink the search phase further
and in some cases there's lots of
symmetries that exist
all right so this is just one way you
can use the cast in
and to dramatically decrease the amount
of computation that you're doing
so in summary uh you can split up the
space into three
main cases this is based on mathematics
known in the 70s
and each case gets progressively more
difficult
so in the first case uh there was a sat
approach
that solved the first case it took
around five minutes there were several
different cast approaches by different
teams
over the years they ran between three
and 55 minutes depending on
the the cast and the implementation we
did the samples cast implementation and
we got it done in seven seconds right so
it was by far the fastest
plus we've got a certificate at the end
that can be verified
all right the second case previously the
last solution was took
16 000 hours this was on a a desktop
machine or a cluster of desktops
we did it in 30 hours all right so the
sat plus cast
was extra exceptionally effective in
that case because there was lots of
symmetries in this case
right there's over a thousand symmetries
this gives us a huge speed up
when we remove them the third case was
the hardest it took around two years
altogether but less than a day in
real time because we farmed it out to
you know a machine with a thousand
processors
uh the the proof is quite large it the
certificate was about 100 over 100
terabytes uh this is in compressed draft
format
uh so but it can be checked and we
formally verified it with a
formally verified uh proof checker
so i mentioned there's a lot of trust
necessary that goes into for example the
previous searches like lam's original
search
there was also an independent
verification of lam search done
a decade ago in 2011. we actually found
discrepancies with both of these
searches not only the original also in
the the independent verification
uh by discrepancies i mean they asserted
the existence of partial projective
planes or the non-existence of partial
projective planes
which actually we found it do exist i've
shown one on the right here this is a 51
point
partial projector plane which was
explicitly asserted
not to exist in the 2011 verification
and we found it right so there must have
been a bug
in the previous search we don't have
access to their source code but we know
it must be
buggy because they didn't find this
partial solution which
should have they should have found uh
although our final results did
correspond we did not find the projected
plane of order 10.
okay so i'm coming back to my promise at
the beginning of the
talk how did we and the williamson
example how do we get up to order 70
right and this is basically to
demonstrate the
[Music]
the how you can use the cast in many
different ways right it's not just about
symmetries
and this is one of the beauties of the
method is that the cast
has a huge storehouse of mathematical
knowledge
right you can use many different
functions in the cast
in many different ways one of them is
based on the
fourier transform in this case so
remember when i had my uh
hadamard matrix i had the sub matrices
each colored in a different color
what you can do is there's a theorem
saying that the discrete fluid transform
of the entries in one of the sub
matrices must have entries of small
magnitude
if it's to be ahead of our matrix and
this can be proven
so what you can do is you when the stat
solver is filling in the entries of the
matrix
eventually it's going to fill in all the
entries in one of the sub matrices
then you can take that sub matrix give
it to the cast
have the casca compute the discrete
fourier transforms
uh entries magnitudes and if they are
too large
you throw it away you block it because
it's never going to extend to a full
head of our matrix
and this is extremely powerful because
almost all matrix almost also matrix are
going to have
some entry with a large magnitude right
almost every time we give a the sat cell
refines a potential
sub matrix and gives it to the cast it's
almost always going to be discarded
so this was basically we use other
theorems as well this is one of the main
reasons why
we're able to go so high
search for williams and matrices of such
a high order
so in conclusion i really want to stress
just how
widely applicable this method is right
it whenever you
have fast verifiable and ex
you want uh expressive searches this is
a great
way to go about it right you could write
your own search
custom written search but you don't want
to reinvent the wheel right
it's very hard to to beat a sad
celebrate search because sat solvers
have been engineered
for decades to be very fast at search
right it's very hard to beat them
on the other hand cases have also been
engineered
for decades to be very fast at doing
mathematical computations
why not use both of the tools in the way
that they were designed to be used right
don't try to shoehorn
you know some kind of cast function into
set right you could imagine
trying to do a discrete for a
transformation it's like it's
it hurts my head just trying to think of
doing something like that right
you wouldn't want to put a discrete
transform uh
in a satin coating right it's something
which is best suited
to do in a computer algebra system or
some kind of math library
all right so use both of the tools in
the ways that are meant to be used
and this uh kind of overcomes the one of
the downsides of assad solver which is
its
lack of expressiveness okay so in the
just one slide on the future work i
really do believe that sapless cast
methods are forever poised
to change what is considered feasible in
mathematical search
i've seen it with my own two eyes right
i come up with some kind of search using
either a cas
or a sat uh solver and it's running okay
and then you put the two together in
just the right way and it just takes off
like a rocket
right it it really really performs very
much faster than uh approaches with
just using one of the techniques
individually so i've seen it happen
again and again
in many different fields so we really
are excited to push this technique
to other fields right so i am looking
for for students check out my website
for for put research positions and
you know like we want people from uh
from different domains as well
uh the last thing i just wanted to
mention is if you are interested
in getting involved in this community
one way that you could do this
is to take go to the sc square workshop
which is happening this year in
august uh it's going to be online so no
traveling you can just
sign in virtually and we have a great
lineup of speakers we have 12 talks over
the two days
and it's a very welcoming community
right and we're explicitly wanting
people
from diverse backgrounds because as i
mentioned if you have that domain
expertise in some other
domain it's very likely that these sort
of surplus
techniques can help solve problems in
your field as well so
with that uh thank everyone for your
time and uh be happy to take any
questions
thank you curtis that was a wonderful
talk moshe already has a question
please go ahead moshe
uh can you unmute moshe
can you make more shape but panelists
moshe can you uh unmute yourself okay
yeah no i had to be moved to two
panelists
yes uh a very very nice talk curtis
you did not mention that the one tla you
do not mention is
smt right that's coming up level of an
smt can you comment on this as an smt
is an example of smt it is sort of like
an
smt uh yeah so i get this a lot of
people
mention this one of the differences is
that
well smt is kind of fixed to a specific
theory normally right
and there's really i don't believe
there's any smt solvers that support say
even complex numbers right it's
definitely not fast fourier transforms
right so this is kind of like an
extension of the uh
dplt framework for smt solvers
so let me see if i let me say it in my
own world so
the approach in smt is usually was to
take
a complete solver for some theory
and then to consider that combination
instead cash is not a complete is not a
complete solver
okay it's just a powerful solver for
whatever it can do
exactly and you're still trying to com
combine it with your so you the same
idea let's combine it with that
and we don't get a complete solver
but we get a very powerful solver that
can handle many many
many pieces of mathematics right exactly
that's exactly right
okay that's how that was that's how we
positioned the first paper on this oh
[ __ ]
thank you uh any other questions
there is a question from stephen got um
so i'm going to read it uh do the
verifiable proofs
combine both the sat and cast reasoning
if so how do you express the cash
reasoning
within draft yeah
that's an excellent question the it
really depends on what functions you
were calling right so
in the symmetry example case uh
what we called this library naughty
which tests the isomorphism of two
graphs
right so in the d-wrap proof you have to
assume these cast clauses
right we just assumed that they were
being generated correctly
but then we have a separate verifier
which is going to check
the the clauses generated correctly for
example in the naughty case
naughty will provide you like i
mentioned that you have those two graphs
which are isomorphic
naughty will provide you with an
explicit labeling of one
the vertices to show that they are
isomorphic so we had a separate
checker which checked the isomorphism of
uh are actually isomorphisms so we
didn't actually have to
rely on naughty by itself
uh another question from yarco
surveilla so are you basically using
cass as an extra constraint propagator
or are you doing something else
you can also use the cast as a
constraint propagator that was not
typically what we were doing
we were using the cast to generate
clauses
that we would put in to the sat solvers
clause database
cool so kurt is i have uh massimo has a
question go ahead massimo
do you have a question yes i do
but i don't know how you realize that
because i
haven't right haven't written anything
anyway
you raise your hand so i thought oh okay
so my question is about
the communication between the math
component and the sub solver
for example in the williams song in the
example of the williamson conjecture you
say that at some point part of the
matrix is
filled and then you test
the fourier transform of that part of
the matrix
so is something that you do like you you
have some trigger and callback
technology or you at some point you just
stop the search or you wait the search
to complete for a satisfiable assignment
how does it work uh so this is a
paradigm that
uh vj pioneer called programmatic sat so
internally to the sat solver you can
call out
to using a callback function to any
library that you want
right so as the sound solver is is
executing the search is going to be
periodically querying
the pubic transform library
i just want to add to what curtis said
so the concept of programmatic search is
very similar to dplt or
cdclt the only dif the main difference
is
that we can particularize the sat solver
for specific instances
it's like a non-uniform model of
computation
so i can say i have this instance
but and i want to make the sat solver
specific to that one
instance whereas uh dplt or cdclt
is for a class of instances another
difference is that in
cdclt the theory part is first order
theories
what is here the theory part is well
arbitrary
and the goal is to kind of provide
feedback on the
on the sat formula
so and do you chain do you change these
goals or like you do it interactively
like do you buffer these calls because i
would expect that
if you want to stop the solver to call
the cast
is like it's a huge uh is a huge
slowdown oh no it's it's a callback
mechanism
so in in many programming languages you
have a callback mechanism
that allows you to inject arbitrary code
and you can compile the solver
with with your code so a programmatic
sat solver is like a poor man's cdc lt
by that i mean that try hacking an smt
solver and
you know you need a couple of phds
before you can get to that point right i
mean
anybody and the point is that with
programmatic sad
the interfaces are so simple they're
very similar but they're much simpler
the
invariants that we impose on them are
simpler
so therefore any user
with you know reasonable programming
background can
extend the sat solver for a very
particular class of instances
for a single instance if they so wish
but but every time you call the math
uh core you stop the solver somehow the
alternate yeah i mean you could think of
it that way yeah so when you call the
mat
yeah so there is when the callback
function is being called
indeed the sat solver you know because
it's sequential the sat solver stops
if you will and then the callback then
feeds back clauses into
the this one into the solver and this is
what we
first proposed in 2015 as part of
mathchuk
and then kurt i took off like a rocket
like that uh
curtis i should i call you carter
um what's uh i'm sorry if i'm uh
asking so many questions but i guess you
have
like very good measures about how much
time you spend
on one side and the other i guess you
really measure this kind of things
so yeah it depends on the problem
sometimes it'll be more than the sad
side sometimes the cast is more
super thick as a question the problems
mentioned in the talks seem to
be those which admit a propositional
encoding i presume
saplus can be used to solve problems
that cannot be encoded propositionally
using
real arithmetic yeah it depends
typically you want like a component of
the problem encoded directly in sat
so you might have functions which you
can't encode into set
but then you call those you call make a
call the cast for those
okay thank you curtis for a fantastic
talk
so clap for everybody else oh
thomas just
uh if you do this what vijay proposes
uh you could find exactly
oh go ahead thomas oh yes yeah my
question is what you said
to to find a specific sub solver for a
specific
interaction problem with cars and sat
and then if you have a specific sub
server then
and solve that transfer all this to the
sat solver
then i think it should work that then
you
ultimately have indirect proof don't you
yes
a specific drug proof yes oh yeah i
think it's an open question we we had
at the talk i think uh when uh pavel
uh um putlock uh gave his talk
um whether it's really um
possible to to encode everything into
extended resolution or
if we do need something which is a
strong approved system
i think it's but i assume it's
impossible it's so drug would work then
but otherwise you wouldn't find a
satsang for that
do you agree i'm not
quite following your question maybe
curtis
uh i think if
uh the question is whether or not a
d-rat proof can be generated when you do
a sad plus guess combination is that the
question
yeah yeah so we do have d-wrap proofs at
the end but like i said
some of the clauses are assumed to be
correct right they're generated from the
cast and that has to have a separate
uh reasoning separately verified
what triggers the callback is that the
callback author's decision or is it up
to the sat solver
so i believe it every time you brought
to a
pr unit propagation right before you're
about to
choose the next variable it will trigger
the call back
right there are many places where the
nathan where you can put the callback
one of them is that when bcp is done and
it's
waiting to either make a decision you
could
use that moment to do a take a partial
assignment and check whether it can be
extended
to a complete assignment and if it
cannot then the cast would return a long
clause
similar to a conflict analysis so we are
extending the conflict analysis in some
way
you could also extend the propagation
method using this so there are many
different points at which
you can add the callback all right
uh thank you curtis for a fantastic talk
that was
very good i clap for everybody again and
now it's my great pleasure